as we kind of enter this cost of living
crisis which has been going on for
people in these communities for a long
time it's only because it's beginning to
affect the lower and upper middle
classes Lifestyles that it's now become
a legitimate area of conversation the
problem of Britain in recent decades has
been the fact that the people who run
the country have absolutely no clue
what's going on where you were born the
people in charge are almost like aliens
in terms of the level of of common
ground that they have with ordinary
people
and it's interesting because politics is
a curious profession where you don't
have to have any prior qualifications
any specialism really you just have to
kind of have the ego
and put yourself forward the politicians
the political classes are democratic
structures but not designed to take
incoming calls but what we have now as I
say that's so deeply unequal that in a
representative democracy the people who
are elected to represent us are
unrepresentative of us but when you're
watching an American activist talking
about white privilege and and then
you're running from you know your your
affluent Suburban in the UK and to you
know Preston Town Center
just accusing people of it so the first
thing is I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about who the [ __ ] are
you talking to and privilege is a term
that is loaded with centuries of
connotations that people in working
class communities use as an insult
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is a
writer activist and performer Darren
McGarvey welcome to trigonometry hello
guys pleasure to be here it's really
great to have you we're going to talk
about your new book The the social
distance between us how remote politics
wrecked Britain it's a really
interesting conversation uh we were just
chanting before we started uh about the
fact that it Harkens back to many of the
issues we started the show talking about
a class-based look at economics and the
world and Society Etc but before we do
tell everybody you've had a very
interesting life story who are you how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life that leads you to
be sitting here talking to us uh well I
grew up in a housing scheme housing
estate in Glasgow called Pollock which
was at the top and bottom of all the
wrong League tables
and uh and so you know I was kind of
subjected to the usual hustle and bustle
of that sort of working class life in a
so-called deprived community
lots to take from uh lots of character
building quite a bit of trauma and
really that just kind of shaped uh my
emotional nature really which I think
was then what propelled me through my
chaotic adolescence but I always had the
passion for writing always had the
passion for
um expressing myself and so I kind of
fell into after realizing I couldn't go
down the acting and realizing I couldn't
go down the music route or the
traditional musical instrument
um then I kind of fell into hip-hop and
in particular rapping because it was a
low entry level in terms of what you
need to acquire before you can start
doing the thing
and that's what I've seen me through a
periods of homelessness and addiction
and alcoholism and then when I got sober
in 2013 I studied journalism for two
years and kind of fell into that and
someone then suggested to me you ever
thought about writing a book and that
was the first time really I had thought
about it because I just thought people
like me don't write books
and uh so I wrote a book and it won the
Orwell prize in 2018 and
I've been doing this professionally ever
since and also it's worth noting that is
the most concise answer I think I've
ever given to a really big question like
tell us about your whole life yeah uh
and you talk about some of the
difficulties uh but he also talked about
it deprived in inverted commas why did
you do that
it's the sort of terminology that
someone looking at a community from a
distance with you is
um because uh for people who live there
they might feel offended uh to be
described in that way they might not
feel necessarily deprived of everything
obviously when you look at the
socio-economic structure of the country
you understand it
um and for reasons we might get into
later uh the system is is rigged against
people who are born in the wrong
postcodes and so what they're deprived
of is Health equality educational
equality and this is Manifest in all of
the life outcomes that many of them will
go and experience
but also I work in class community in a
working class culture is a very
beautiful thing and often in our in our
British culture and in Scotland as well
um there's this idea that working class
culture is a kind of infantile culture
that's just waiting to kind of go
through some sort of puberty phase to
become middle class and actually in
working class communities we have our
own way of seeing things we have our own
way of expressing things we have
different thresholds and sensitivities
from from traditionally middle class
people give us some examples
well I mean if you if you uh
we live in an age just know well you
know loved experience and Trauma or big
discussion points right and I think
that's important you know because there
are things that we carry with us in life
that if an address can can lead to us
making poor decisions or have a negative
experiences
but someone who grows up in a pretty
affluent background their threshold for
what they consider traumatic uh or what
they consider shocking uh is is a bit
different because they've been exposed
to different material conditions and so
if the worst thing that's happened to
someone in their life is that a pet has
died then that genuinely for their
threshold and Baseline of trauma is a
painful event
but if you grow up in a poorer Community
you've been excluded from school you
grew up at a time where teachers were
just slapping kids around
um and uh you know people are dying left
right and Center all the time because a
convergent Health crises and
inequalities then your your threshold
for what you consider traumatic or
shockings is almost hilariously high and
so you might find something funny that
someone on the other side of the train
tracks finds really really shocking or
insensitive and I'm always fascinated as
a writer and that that that that rub
that point of friction between the two
because I see it as as part of my role
as a writer to do what other people have
done for me which is describe those
points of friction and try to articulate
it the way that both sides can
understand which for me is an exciting
thing to sit down and try and do but
that's that's just one area I think
where class differences are very obvious
it's such a powerful point you made
there and you because what you're trying
to do is make the point that both sides
can hear yet in our culture we very
rarely do that because we see the other
side of the people who disagree with us
as our enemies we dehumanize them and
I'm certainly guilty of this I'm Not
Innocent of this and as a result you
just
make everybody go a little bit further
apart yeah and it's a hard thing to
resist because it's part of our nature
to thinking that in those tribal terms
and so we have to work fairly hard to
always try and bring ourselves back to
that place of of mindfulness about the
the kind of cul-de-sacs that we can fall
into when we're trying to think about
things that are complicated
and one of the things that actually
helps me is the fact that because I'm in
recovery from alcohol and addiction I
have to be vigilant about certain things
because you know for me the problem
isn't necessarily the alcohol or the
drugs the problem is the emotional
nature so I've certain factory settings
as a person whether that's because of
trauma whether that's because of the
environment or just cultural genetic
chance whatever it is if I'm not working
on myself it's very easy for me to slip
into selfishness dishonesty fear
resentment which obviously will help you
rise through the ranks of a lifelong
Institution
[Laughter]
it has to be for someone who has to be
very Vigilant about uh
being under that kind of emotional
duress for too long until the point
where I end up trying to numb
the discomfort or the depression or
whatever with alcohol then I always have
to be on guard for these emotions and so
really what that that that brings to me
is a person is uh when I'm having a good
day is that um I try to approach most
people who have set a level of good
faith no not always on social media is
that possible and you could go through
my history of social media you could
find exams and go well what about this
and what about that but the point is
that I'm always trying to get back to
that place where I recognized it we're
all working off of a caricature of the
other side whether it's an individual
whether it's a whole political ideology
and you know you've got to be kind of
you've got to have a better humility
about what you can truly understand as
one person and you say that
people who grew up in an African African
affluent background don't particularly
understand what Working Class People
have to go through
so let's explode some of the myths
Darren what do Working Class People have
to go through people who grew up in
deprived backgrounds that affluent
people don't understand
well the first thing is that Working
Class People by virtue of the social
possession are over exposed to economic
shocks uh economic transitions
Unemployment uh social policy and so
this means that life in a working class
Community is always in a state of
constant transition which leads to
people often particularly those where
there isn't a dual income household
maybe there's a prevalence of addiction
at home some sort of uh dysfunction at
play this means that people are always
really standing on very uh shaky
foundations yes and uh and and and you
know as we kind of enter this cost of
living crisis which has been going on
for people in these communities for a
long time it's only because it's
beginning to affect the lower and not
upper middle classes Lifestyles that
it's now become a legitimate area of
conversation before if you were poor or
before if you worked hard in your money
then go far enough it's because you were
spending it wrong and you were making
the wrong decisions no because it's
middle class people were starting to
look at the systemic factors and the
cost of energy and all of the contextual
issues that actually put strain on
households so when you're growing up in
that sort of environment then you become
hardened to certain things uh you may
become uh you may become cynical of
institutions in fact you that you might
not make much effort to discern between
a teacher and a police officer and a
social worker you begin to see this all
as the man and so you know I write in
the book about this Mantra that you have
in in working class communities in
particular this don't grasp Mantra this
idea that any level of cooperation with
law enforcement is a betrayal and
something that will Mark you out uh as
as as as as a bad one or a wrong and in
a certain community and this is true in
prison culture or as among young people
and even certain uh you know criminal
criminal Enterprises and even people who
aren't involved in that there's a lot of
Psychosocial pressure to take that view
towards institutions and that is I I go
in the book on to say that don't grasp
Mantra it's a class-based concern it's
based on an understanding that when you
look at the prison system and you look
at the criminal justice system what you
see is it's full of people who look and
sound
like you
and so the idea that cooperating with it
in any way is going to be of benefit to
you just is is is riseable and that's
just one idea of how cultural attitudes
are shaped by different material
conditions because it wasn't until very
recently with a shocking crimes
um and the shocking incompetence of of
of the Met
um that middle class people started
coming out and and getting in the face
of the police because before the police
were there to serve the middle classes
in the middle class of the people
falling the corpse on you there's loads
and loads of things that I could go
through whether it's cultural social or
economic where there are really
pronounced differences but the real
challenge is not necessarily noticing
them and acknowledging them the new
challenges then culturally how do you
communicate that up the structure well
this is what I was going to ask you
about because this is fundamental to
your book and to your argument which is
that whatever people understand and know
about each other the problem of Britain
in recent decades has been the fact that
the people who run the country have apps
absolutely no clue what's going on where
you were born yes and and and people
might assume well of course there's
always going to be a certain level of
inequality and there's always going to
be gaps and knowledge but what we're
talking here is almost
the people in charge are almost like
aliens
in terms of the level of of common
ground that they have with ordinary
people
and it's interesting because politics is
a curious profession where you don't
have to have any prior qualifications
any specialism really you just have to
kind of have the ego to put yourself
forward and in a way that's the way it
should be because it should be
accessible to everyone yes but again
because of class differences then really
since the Blair period what we've seen
is the rise of the career politician and
a real drop in the percentage of people
from what in class areas and so it's
interesting because if if you're
watching the news right or you're
reading a report an investigative report
you're not going to read and
investigative report by someone who's
just writing out what they think based
on what they've heard right there's
someone who's been sent out there to get
quotes to observe the situation close
um and uh same as when you get on an
airplane you don't want to get in an
airplane with someone who's never flown
a plane oh I just finished this emulator
right we're off to Majorca you'll be
like oh no no no no no it would be good
if you had some practical experience of
of some sort but then you see how much
Ryanair charging you think yeah
so with politics what we have is not
just politicians who don't have any
reward experience but we have a whole uh
ecosystem of advice and information
which is is really kind of uh
contributed to by some people from
similar backgrounds and they make very
little content attacked West reality as
it's experienced by a lot of other
people and this really shows when you
look at things like welfare reform uh I
mean those those reforms no one thinks
the welfare state should be generous no
one thinks that it should be easy to get
benefits we understand the system will
be open to abuse but we're talking here
about tens of thousands of people with
disabilities attempting suicide off the
back of trying to interact with the
Department of working pensions and
that's because the government is more
interested in listening to the advice of
corrupt American Insurance companies uh
then as with people with loved
experience and that's a real problem the
system the politicians the political
classes our Democratic structures
they're not designed to take incoming
calls and the minute that you try to
communicate stuff up the structure you
just met with tremendous uh resistance
and I think that this issue of proximity
is a real fundamental problem for a
democracy generally but particularly in
the UK right now
and that was what the MP system sort of
was meant to avoid or prevent that from
happening because you had your local MP
that's who you went to see they were
meant to be connected to the community
but again they've they've they've kind
of gone around that in that you see and
all political parties do that you know
they parachute MPS in who've got no
connection with the area wasn't Peter
mandelson MP for heart nipple yeah well
he was one of a number of of new Labor
uh uh leading lights that were pretty
much parachuted in there on the basis
that these communities will vote labor
because they can't vote conservative and
that was true for enough time but I
think really the real vulnerability with
representative democracy comes in
whether the society is is is more equal
or more unequal gonna have a true
equality and I don't think anyone would
argue that that's possible or even
desirable ah there's some people yeah
you know I know when you get it you know
you know that there is a place for merit
and as a place for hard work
an equitable situation but what we have
now as a society that's so deeply
unequal that in a representative
democracy the people who are elected to
represent us are unrepresentative of us
yes and so this just creates natural
dysfunction at every level of governance
um and then obviously the the further up
the food chain you go the more
resilience you have in the face of
accountability uh the more you can Dock
and dive you can rely on your powerful
social networks and connections to to
build you out of problems and so there's
at the opposite end you have a very
punitive system where a lot of people
live in fear of being pulled up by an
institution for something relatively
minor well at the top you have people
engaged in all sorts of of corruption
openly and uh we're just so desensitized
to it now it's just a topsy turvey
system in the United Kingdom and quite
peculiar I would say I I agree with you
and France is probably even more so but
uh the question I was going to ask you
about
um you know when we see you asked us
before we started when we we've been
doing this for four and a half years and
when we started this was one of the
things the question I'm about to ask is
one of the things we were trying to work
out because what you're talking about is
basically looking at people's
circumstances and going if you grow up
in this sort of environment these are
the challenges that are going to be in
front of you and if you grow up in a
different environment these will be the
challenges and that seems to me to make
a lot of sense where you grew up how
much money you had whether you had two
parents did you have a stable place at
home did you go to a good school these
are all things that will absolutely
undoubtedly affect your life outcomes
but there was a moment when the left
stopped looking at things like that or
suddenly stopped listening as much to
people who thought like that and started
to look at people on a different basis
you know skin color sexual orientation
uh gender Etc
and that the con the kind of
conversation you were trying to
encourage sort of went by the wayside
would you agree with me on that I would
agree the level of culture yes yeah um
intersectionality really just um erupted
through uh our social media in the kind
of mid-2010s
uh around about the same time as the
brexit uh
um Foods were beginning to appear in
culture and I remember that being a
really tough time I remember that being
a very tough time in a very confusing
time as a as a lefty in in his mid-20s
um and Sunday was a pretty fun grasp of
language and uh the basic intellectual
Concepts on the left what I didn't
understand was the emotional attitude uh
that I was I was seeing
um at times where people were coming
with these uh ideas around uh professor
Kimberly crenshaw's intersectionality
analysis which I think is a valid
analysis I think is an analysis that
warrants uh study
um because it was created to understand
how women of color in the United States
experience is compounded by gender and
and that in and of itself is an
important thing to understand and I
don't think you're going to find too
many people that would say it isn't what
happens when a bunch of white middle
class people get their hands on it it's
the same thing that happens with my
middle class people get their hands on
most things you know and there's an
underpinning of Hysteria there's a
complete tone deafness to class Dynamics
particularly around class and these
thresholds for trauma that we discussed
earlier and so very very early on as I
had my first few run-ins like all of us
did on the left
um particularly around really sensitive
areas around immigration
um then I I could see that that that's
it being cooked up uh that's cultural
prong of what came to be known as the
left was actually more liberal in its uh
and and it's overconfidence shall we say
and it was always going to crash down
and and be exploited by agitators on the
right who very wisely could see it was
creating another reservoir of resentment
that was only needing to be appropriated
for for cultural War uh resentments and
uh I think I came to a point where I
started to understand
that social media was certainly
magnifying the the true extent of what
was going on and actually that whole
time the Trade union movement was still
working away organizing and that to me
is what the left is it's organized
resistance and understanding of
collective bargaining and understanding
of industrial relations being in
communities being in close proximity
speaking in a language in a torn at the
common man and women can understand and
that's been running completely parallel
to this cultural world that's really
taking this into Stage and I think with
the
um with the rise of uh the Trade union
leaders you know Sharon Greyhound
Dempsey uh Mick Lynch what you're seeing
is how captivating a working-class
person can be when they know what
they're talking about they're pretty
sincere and they don't have this kind of
conditioned reverence for media and Posh
politicians they just get in there and
tell it like it is and for me that's the
clear delineation on the left between
the cultural War stuff and the actual
let's organizer and machine your
condition no no I I agree with you on
that but I I suppose what I'm getting at
is it's you say the word trade unions
have been working when I'm sure they
have but I would argue the collapse of
the red wall for example is a direct
consequence of the labor party being
quite unsure about whether they are on
the side of working people of all Races
and genders and whatever yeah or whether
these narrower concerns are where their
priorities should lie it could be a
contributing factor certainly I think
also the the a lot of new labor chickens
came home to rest as I say you're
talking about mandelson being parachuted
in a former mining communities and all
of that you know have you ever seen that
clip of him going to the fish and chip
shop you've ever seen this and they they
offer mushy peas and he goes no no I
won't have the guacamole
and so you know that that was always
going to be time limited
um because it was based on the premise
these communities will always vote labor
because they are the our possession is
much worse for them but then once you've
already taught it once you've sought
acrossed a taboo and then you become
desensitized to that so then it becomes
easier for them to do it again so that
was always a kind of House of Cards that
was going to fall there was chronic
under investment in a lot of these
communities and and for me and what I
say in the book I think the True Legacy
of new labor is that managerial
paternalism so it was a new kind of
class war where it wasn't Thatcher
sitting just basically saying [ __ ] a
lot he's you know I closed down where
you're working if you can't find another
job that's your fault but those are
bookies and there's a chippy and there's
an off license on your street so if you
can't get a job there go and spend all
your benefit money there you know that
was basically her vision of an economy
and what happened with new labor was
they they adopted this more pleasing to
the ear rhetoric which helped to sort of
cloak the economics of statutism which
Blair partly was elected because he'd
committed to continuing them
um and a kind of red velvet glove you
know but parallel to that what you had
was the the emergence of this idea of
the working class person is vulgar and
infantile and always kind of Wheeling
and dealing and you know so that you're
Jeremy Kyle show your little Britain and
obviously everything is of its time and
I'm not saying we go where I find to
come and we say oh that thing that felt
okay at the time is immoral now we
understand it with a passage of time
most stuff starts to look a bit dodgy on
somewhere where I'm sure there's
interview well at some point but but
really that there was a there was a
certain kind of vindictiveness that
revealed the middle class bigotry uh the
informed sophisticated liberal
compassionate middle classes who would
be empowered by the Blair Administration
to get out there and to work in class
communities and teach people how to
speak right and teach people how to
dress properly and and really began to
hold the keys
um for for working class advancement and
you Advanced by learning to conceal your
working classness you Advanced by
drawing in your accent by wearing a
Blazer instead of a hoodie and these are
things I'm describing to any working
class person watching will intuitively
know even if they haven't heard the
articulated before and and really that's
that's now why you have a kind of
poverty industry infrastructure which
has obviously been left to do a lot of
the essential workers the state has kind
of withdrawn from many areas but at the
same time it's still a kind of class
Warfare in the sense that Working Class
People are there as clients although
there is lived experience people who
tell their story and then go away they
don't have very little say over how
these organizations are running that's
that's a class-based society if you ever
wanted a definition
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
when we talk about you know the labor
party on and how it's abandoned
working-class people I just and we used
to work in a very liberal industry in
inverted Commerce which was a comedy
industry and I used to get these very
well-educated you know very wealthy
people talking about white privilege and
you just go what are you talking about
do you think someone who grew up on the
breadline in Middlesbrough or Sunderland
is privileged in any shape or form and
then they would just had this abject
horror that they didn't involve to labor
of course and of course they're not
going to vote labor man you've been
condescending them to them for the last
four years yeah I I remember the first
time I was kind of encountered some of
these Concepts uh that came out of the
Horizon of intersectionality and I think
if you're sitting with someone and
they're giving you a context for where
this term applies
um and and uh the the various layers to
it then it's not a difficult concept to
wrap your brain around but what happens
is uh if you have a young activist you
know who's in the kind of prime of their
campaign in life they're setting out to
change the world they have lots of
energy and they have lots of time very
little responsibilities or Real World
experience
it's something that just feels
intuitively correct to them and then
they get out there and they just start
throwing the term around
um and sometimes they'll they'll apply
it uh inappropriately or sometimes
they'll apply it with a certain
emotional Surety and a judgmental kind
of accusatory tone which actually
undermines the opportunity to persuade
someone of the virtue of of such a
concept or the validity of such a
concept and that that's really the kind
of what I would say is is the
emotionally illiterate underbelly of a
lot of the activism that we did see over
the last few years it's based on uh on
conducting yourself with a certain level
of certainty despite limited life
experience plus the term White Privilege
makes more sense when you're discussing
it in an American context where the
ratio divides are more historic and more
pronounced and more institutional not to
say that there isn't elements of that
here but when you're watching an
American activist talking about white
privilege
um and and then you're running from you
know your your affluent Suburban in the
UK and to you know Preston Town Center
just accusing people of it so the first
thing is I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about who the [ __ ] are
you talking to and privilege is a term
that is loaded with centuries of
connotations that people in working
class communities use as an insult right
so the the cultural difference there is
so Stark that someone who says they're
about equality
doesn't understand that you have to
factor class in an intersectional
analysis even if you're just looking at
it in terms of how you convene your
message how are you campaigning what is
your strategy and uh I think that this
was why it was rejected because a lot of
us on the left we were too slow to
respond to that the issues were so
contentious and so numerous and then you
throw immigration into the mix which
really tears the left into because
there's the commitment to anti-racism
which is obviously historic to the left
but then there's the class solidarity
part of it you've seen Eddie Dempsey's
historic remarks Being Framed in certain
ways that review how difficult that
Canyon is to bridge sometimes so yeah I
mean we dropped the ball on that but uh
we always learn from these no I love how
carefully you think and speak about
these issues I really really do let me
ask you something about
you know it might be a challenging
question I suppose but how much of this
is about the fact that
the jobs aren't really there as much for
people who are quote unquote working
class there's just not that many
working-class jobs anymore you know you
talked about Thatcher the pits have been
closed down the mines the the steel
works the whatever it's all been
outsourced or got rid of
um is it not that is is there not that
much harder to build working-class
solidarity where you don't have the
community as much as you did and
therefore you do have a lot of
unemployment you do have more crime etc
etc etc yeah obviously we are undergoing
and even without of course the living
crisis and what's going on in Ukraine
and all the geopolitics of things and
just an incompetent conservative
government
um we would still be heading into a
massive economic transition because of
big data and Automation and Technology
generally yes and normally that should
be a great thing wouldn't it this idea
hang on so that means a lot of these
hard jobs are going to be done by robot
so this is going to free people up but
we haven't got the next part really
figured out yet we've got all the
efficiency built in in that I will take
care of itself but what did people do
when they become soft plus to
requirements permanently and so what
they're they've been floating in recent
years and you hear this you know from
Obama's Institute and Blair's Institute
and all of that they're talking about
how people will have to train and
retrain and change careers multiple
times and really that's an attempt to
kind of normalize precarity you know
because the reality is if you're if
you're um if you are working for low
Wages that's hard enough right you're
constantly just one of the definitions
of working class is not just a
relationship to the labor market is how
hard you have to fight just to get your
basic needs met and that's becoming you
know a really difficult struggle for
people now so the next part of it then
you know if you were thinking forward
you would be thinking okay so we need an
integrated uh transport infrastructure
that's free like a Health Service right
we need to find ways to bring down the
cost of living people so that if you're
in low paid work you're not got all
these other expenses and that's the sort
of idea that just gets shut down
intuitively that's how successful the
rate have been economically that that is
the sort of rantings of a mad person
this idea the uh the the the the trains
and undergrounds uh you can just walk
onto them like you can walk into a
public park you know because the cost of
Transport alone is a massive strain and
people from working class communities
they have to travel further and further
to their place of work they have to
travel back they're being told not to
use cars and so you know this will be
the next area where they're shamed for
their lifestyle choices and their
economic decisions he's driving a car
and eating a burger in the car you know
it'll be like when lockdown they'll fall
on them fall on them box and then going
home with our big [ __ ] Gardens and
our chicken huts and all that so it's
it's difficult
um and you don't really have you have a
you have a political class that really
views the world from the the vantage
point of of corporate Executives which
is a valid vantage point to including
the mix but the skills are tipped too
far yeah I suppose my only question on
that would be and I I'm probably on
economics I'm certainly not on the left
I don't know if I'm on the right but I'd
probably position myself someone and
said to the only question I have is I'm
in intuitively all for getting barriers
out of people's ways I I I just think
that's really important I think the most
important thing is that people are able
to succeed if they're talented and look
you no doubt have had to work extra hard
because of your background to be sitting
here having a chat about your brilliant
book no doubt about that and that is a
problem that you will always be around
by the way we're never going to get rid
of it entirely but I'm all for getting
the the barriers out of people's ways
the difficulty is in a society like
Britain where we do already pay a lot of
tax yeah we all pay a lot of tags the
poor pay a lot of tax the middle class
pay a lot of tax the rich those that
can't evade and avoid tax they also pay
a lot of tax how do we you know how do
we keep paying for all these things that
we would like to have so I don't know if
that's about the right or maybe I'm not
reflecting the Viewpoint of the right I
just wonder how we pay for these very
good things that we would like to put in
place yeah I mean it's it's a difficult
question now that we've sold off all our
assets you know because obviously this
is one of the things that Scandinavian
countries have tremendous foresight yeah
you know we have this big boom okay
let's create a fund for a rainy day yeah
you know and that's why they they no
longer have more equal societies they
have happier societies and yeah they pay
more tax but they understand
the investment so they understand the
benefit of it whereas when people pay
higher levels of tax in this country or
they've been with us horror stories
about the NHS being run into the ground
and trains not being on time so they
think this money's just being poured
into some kind of hole and it's really
just because of the economic
mismanagement
um at the top level of society where
people who have greater levels of wealth
have a greater leverage with politicians
and so decisions are taken in the short
term for electoral reasons that really
place at one end of the country
with the other and then there's all the
work of the center ground the paper over
that with all of the unifying rhetoric
well at the same time really pressing
accelerator pedal down on the economic
policies that divide us and entrench
things so for example the marketization
of the English education system it was
kind of it was it was pitched as this is
uh this is going to be an expansion of
choice this is going to lead to
Innovation and competition and it did
for the middle class schools in the
middle class parents want to set up
their own schools but for the working
classes they go to the school that's on
the doorstep right and so in a
marketized economy then you have parents
parachute and then the catchment areas
the kids grades inflate the house prices
the house prices inflate the kids grades
and this just becomes a little
Prosperity bubble and meanwhile all the
people who grow up there and go to
school there they all think that it's
all going well for them because they're
just great people and they're people
over here who not only have less money
per head for the pupils but also they
have a more diverse educational culture
with very specific strains on it because
of the the imprint that poverty and
stress leaves on many of the pupils who
are going there and so there's just a
complete lack of understanding or any
attempt to account for any of that
um and that's just an education you know
you you don't even get any the
independent sector I mean these are just
onshore tax Havens that benefit the
parents uh who send their kids there as
much as the kids who go there and they
just function as pipelines to the main
professions and you know that's just I
would just I would I would I don't know
how you could phase out or close down
private education particularly
culturally in the UK but I would say as
a national security risk I would frame
it as a national security interest that
you can actually just get a bunch of
absolute nubbins who all went to the
same school just being pumped didn't it
the country's main institutions by
virtue of the fact that they went to
that school despite the fact that the
evidence is in that they're of nowhere
unless you're defining mirror is just
absolute ruthlessness hard to argue
against yeah I mean the one way actually
that you do get at these schools if you
do want to get at them is every public
or private school in this country is a
registered charity so you take away
their charitable status that's why it
will really annoyed me about corbyn when
he was up we're going to abolish private
schools I'm like you're never going to
do that shut up that's a virtue signal
if you truly want to actually maybe you
know attack these institutions if that's
what you want to do then you go for the
charitable status and you ask them to
justify it because many of them can't
yeah and I mean I've done a lot of I've
visited many uh private schools in it's
another thing you know when you're
you've got a kind of low resolution
understanding of the other you go to
private school you meet teachers who
understand perfectly well
um the inherent problem of such an
institution they often go there because
they get discounts for their own
children yeah and they know that they'll
give their kids a great opportunity to
to get the best possible education what
you find in the private school sector
also is almost compared to State
schooling uh a kind of utopian scenario
where the curriculum is designed around
uh the child
being the child's opportunities and
experiences being optimized to the
furthest most point so even just how
ideas planned out leisure activities
these are always starting in the grounds
of or surrounded by Green Space windows
with natural light coming in the the the
the they are and vitamins which optimize
human potential and there's a lot that
the state could learn from how to design
a school and design a curriculum well
quite as someone who did go to a private
school for part of my education I I I'm
totally support getting rid of the
charitable status by the way uh to the
extent that I understand that issue but
equally I think we need to make the rest
of the schools better rather than
tearing things down that makes more
sense to me oh absolutely because if if
if parents with a bit more money thought
that they could save 20 30 40 Grand a
year by going to a state school which is
performing just as well then it would be
a no-brainer for them I mean I'm not I'm
not sitting here saying everyone who
goes to private school is a multi
multi-millionaire I know many parents
take a big big hit but they see that as
a long-term investment in their children
in their family as a as a structure well
and as you say in a country where seven
percent of pupils end up making up 50 of
the top jobs it is a long-term
investment there's no question oh
definitely and that's when you're just
looking at the kind of cold hard
economics of it of course it makes a lot
of sense from that perspective but the
long-term damage that that level of
inequality does to our country's culture
and politics and economy
um it's just it's undeniable at this
point and and for me the the uh
the big difficulty obviously is just
culturally the needle has moved so far
in terms of the right
and a free Society uh for the rich to
just do whatever they want and then I
sense in principle that should be right
but see when we talk about a free press
now or a free education system what we
really mean is
the rate of a billionaire buys many
newspapers as they want you know and
push out their message that suits their
politics and Suits their economics
um and and so sometimes I think we get
confused about what our free society
means it's it's it's the balancing of
everyone's freedoms and making sure that
people with the most don't get to race
too far ahead because then they start
shaping everything in their own in in
the shape of their own desires and their
own needs and sometimes these can't be
reconciled with people who live in the
deprived communities and look you're
making such a great Point like how can
you possibly even if you you know with
the best will in the world even if you
go into politics with the purest of
intentions but you come from a highly
privileged background how can you
possibly Implement policies that are
going to work for Working Class People
if you've never met one yeah how is that
going to work it's just not I know and
the chances are the the difficult
conversation with whatever executive of
whatever multinational corporation you
have to have with someone that you know
personally so we all know what it's like
I write about it in the book difference
right deference is something that's
really understated in terms of class
relations in this country so I remember
um interviewing sir Tom Hunter who's one
of you know Scott poster boy of Scotland
entrepreneurialism we saw this Sports
division brand for 300 million and he's
now a billionaire
and he does a lot of philanthropy and I
was doing a TV series uh about class and
I interviewed him and I had met him
before but I was interviewing them and
so I was my job was not just to hear
from him my job was to scrutinize and
ask questions and try and find out an
uncomfortable spot to put them in about
the contradiction and philanthropy and
uh and uh he he I found it very
difficult to speak frankly which is
really odd for me and uh so we did this
show and we filmed that and the show was
ended up being about that interaction
ended up being about the one thing that
we we wanted it to be about but I came
away from it thinking no this was about
something else and then what I realized
was that he was the only contributor
that we had relaxed the covered
restrictions for the BBC's covered
restrictions were were double what the
government's restrictions were so we had
to have a two meter length of tape
between two contributors who were
walking in open space and uh this was
what happened with every contributor but
for some reason we just instinctively
relaxed this for Tom even though he
didn't wanted to be treated any
differently so I had to walk in the mud
Tom got told to walking the path I got
moved into the shitty cold car he got
moved into the big car and suddenly I
went from being like the the centerpiece
of this TV operation to just realizing
where I was in the pecking order and
then when it came time to get Frank with
him the ones came from me very very
slowly and difficult and that's
different you know so when a politician
sits in a room where Jeff Bezos types
you know and who's at the top of the
society they're going a narrative
between the legs they're not going
anywhere listen I have a mandate from
population right of hundreds of millions
of people and uh we need to get a fair
deal here because I know you're offering
a lot of jobs but we're subsidizing your
business with our welfare state because
your wages are too low so you need to
get that sorted up Jeff
no it's Biden gonna near sorry about
this Jeff have you got any ideas about
what I could do around the American
economy why don't you get the guys from
Pfizer and we'll sit down we'll bang
heads we'll come up with a new deal you
know to make sure you all still get paid
while we try to make Society about less
horrific for the poor and that
difference is a big problem you'll know
you've met famous people but you know
when you meet someone you may get back
you stay I don't get Star Struck really
but it's hard to happen now Darren it's
hard to ever
let's hardly have a Frank conversation
with someone who's used to being [ __ ]
footed around and treated very
delicately and uh culturally that is one
of the factors that means that the
people who need to have spoken to them
often never hear the truth well look
with the obvious solution to all of this
because I think the way you are talking
about it you're talking about all the
different things that make up the
experience of people in different social
stratas and that makes perfect sense but
that would all be remedy date by more
representation of Working Class People
in the political Halls of power and when
the unions were really at the peak
that was happening but now again I this
is not because I want to jump on up and
down on the corpse of the labor party
I'm just being honest with you about
what I see you have a labor party now
whose latest intake is all of these sort
of like 24 year old graduates from some
University who I I don't with all
possible respect to them think have any
[ __ ] idea what you're talking about
right so it's I we I we jump up and down
on the Tory party all the time on this
show but I don't see the labor party
answering your call either do you
no
um because what star must chosen after
kind of sounding uh vaguely original in
the beginning uh
as reheated blairism to the letter I
mean if you understand the trajectory of
blairism from its development
takes execution
then you understand what stormers
attempting here right now obviously
there's a new context and it has to be
um dealt with but your colleagues on the
left will say to you well to Tony Blair
brought us three election victories in a
row the most successful labor prime
minister all of that yeah I mean it's
not that it's I wouldn't I wouldn't say
it was the most successful really
because I mean if you look at the real
giants of British politics
the only discard the only remnant of
Blair's Legacy is is the discussion
about his character
so everything that new labor achieved
under Blair or did under Blair is gone
right and couldn't be unfair what about
Northern Ireland Darren come on well I
mean that's all Epicurious right now
though isn't it what I mean is the
things that he'd done he didn't want any
arguments on
so they're still contentious right you
could say the same thing about the
welfare state you can say the same thing
about Thatcher I mean these were
Paradigm shifts I see what you're saying
yeah so he didn't change the country um
he didn't bring it home and that's why I
wanted to stay online that's why exactly
so what happened was he sowed the seeds
of his own destruction which all
politicians do but he didn't quite wrap
it up in a nice neat little ball that
history has found for your athletes and
your factors and your churches and and
now the debate really about Blair is was
he a big giant of politics or did
everything he did just tons of [ __ ] and
I recognize that you know that that
might be a a kind of um maybe a cynical
or mischievous way to characterize it
but I I just wouldn't be no I think
you're making it I wouldn't be putting
Blair in the same category it really
remains to be seen
um I think you're making a very fair
point but I interrupted you when you
started talking about kirstan like he
went and blessed directions more about
that sorry what what what that aspect of
blairism is is the center ground where
you attempt to
um rhetorically reconcile
competing groups in society by speaking
in vague terms of values so everyone
wants equality everyone wants fairness
everyone wants to society where hard
work is rewarded
um everyone wants every sprinkle not
everyone no five billion people in
Scotland that don't care but um everyone
saw me sprinkle of britishness over
everything to just feel you know are we
but maybe not five million maybe 2
million who knows yeah but the the the
thing about it is that actually the
economic program that will be brought
forward
will be a commitment to the status quo
which is already deeply unfair and
deeply unjust so you can paper over the
cracks for a while with the comfort and
rhetoric and if you can generate
everybody economic growth everyone will
forget for a while but the minute that
the [ __ ] hits the fan then the flaws and
the fundamentals of the economy uh
reveal themselves again and that's when
you create you know the the levels of
resentment and apathy and skepticism
that leads to massive Dropout of voting
which is a gift to the privileged
parties it leads to things like that
like the the the debate around
immigration that really became the
momentum behind brexit and that all goes
down to Blair economics I see what
you're saying correct me if I'm wrong
but what I'm hearing out of what you're
saying is
the economic structure now is such that
when the [ __ ] hits the fan as you say
we're not all in it together no the rich
just get richer the comfortable just get
more comfortable and the working people
get left behind yeah because of the
flaws and the way the system is
organized yeah because they're they're
so Overexposed so even where they're
managing
their household budgets reasonably well
and not doing the deal in terms of
trying to be responsible with the
resources that they have
um that's one rise in energy it's just
wiping them out yeah and that that you
know you can't really you'd have to be
really really confident to to try and
argue that this is an equitable
settlement economically right now the
only Silver Lining of of a situation
like covid and a pandemic is that it
really revealed in high definition the
inequalities and how Overexposed working
people were not just to the virus but to
everything else around it the lockdowns
the the inaccessibility of Health
um I mean even just the most canceled
numbers are going through the roof now
because people haven't been getting to
the dentist which is where this [ __ ] is
packed up so just so many ways that
Working Class People get hit and um and
you know I'm not certain here saying I
have all the answers I think part of my
job or the job of people like me who
have spent time on the front line is
really just to try and find new ways to
articulate what we see in taking
account of the fact that there are
people there who do want to do the right
thing but they need someone to frame it
for them in terms that they understand
relative to their and experience of
working class communities and that's
that's what I try to contribute to
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
this sort of frozen food of and then
just bought questions at them before
they can escape uh not the American ones
as they have guns and you'd have to be
extra careful with the females as that's
how I got in trouble last time
do you really imagine you're gonna get
Douglas Murray near the frozen food
aisle if you want to ask our incredible
guest questions and have access to
phenomenal behind the scenes content
then you have to be on our locals that's
right for only seven dollars a month you
get incredible extra content behind the
scenes footage giveaways and also the
chance to be part of an incredible
Community where you can meet and hang
out with like-minded people you get
access to our American Vlogs as we
travel across the country interviewing
Our Heroes an extra 20 minutes of our
viral Sam Harris episode as he discusses
his approach to covert we're also going
to start doing giveaways of exclusive
trigonometry merchandise like this a
poster from our Edinburgh show signed by
both of us and also a House of Lords
Teddy which you can only get in the
House of Lords signed by the one and
only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
so Darren moving on you you spend a
large portion of the book you're talking
about homelessness yeah and the and as
someone who grew up in London when I
grew up in London in the 80s it was
nowhere near as wealthy as it was now
there was a lot you know people weren't
as wealthy you know there's a lot more
Working Class People there was a lot
more working-class communities in London
but there wasn't the same level of
homelessness I go and I walk around
London now and it's much wealthier and
you see people who are more
ostentatiously rich
but the homelessness has just gone
through the roof yeah it's um again this
comes down to housing policy
so we have had a situation where the
social housing stock has not only been
left have fallen and disrepair over the
last 30 or 40 years
but also culturally as I mentioned
earlier with blairism
uh does this Cult of home ownership no
no the concept of home ownership and
property ownership is a good one and the
idea was Democratic that anyone should
be able to own property not just your
landed gentry if people run property
they can pass something down to the Next
Generation and this will become a little
Prosperity cycle and if everyone gets a
fair crack why the hell not the problem
you have now is you can pay a thousand
pound a month on rent for five years and
a bank won't give you a mortgage for 400
pounds a month because they're worried
that you're irresponsible with your
money so that's Topsy Turvy economics
then you also have welfare reforms
um which don't take account of the
alternative family structures and
Dynamics and working class communities
where trauma family members in prison
alcoholism single parent families all
these different setups that are adopted
by households to deal with circumstances
you have a benefit system that's
punitive that's not state not really to
recognize the unique circumstances that
each household faces and so the the
safety net that's there
uh when you do decide to go for the
homeownership and Pen the whole housing
economy on that uh the safety nets also
removed for people who don't fit that
template
and an example of this would be removing
child benefit for young people no no
housing benefits sorry this is one of
the most callous things that the Cameron
Osborne uh Administration done
um their whole idea was that this would
just incentivize people and it benefits
at a young age what they don't realize
is like myself a lot of young people who
grow up in poverty they have to leave
the family home a lot younger and they
they don't even have that education in
the bag and so without that housing
benefit they end up on the street or
sleeping on couches they just become
inherently residentially unstable but
you have welfare reforms which are
underpinned by this assumption that
really anybody who wants to get on
benefits is kind of a bit dodgy in some
way and there's just so many examples of
how welfare reform impacts and drives
homelessness whether it's Food Bank use
this Universal Credit thing or there's
just this arbitrary amount of time a
person has to wait before they get paid
of six weeks
um it's weird because when the
self-employment grants were getting
handed out to the middle class people to
underwrite all their gym memberships and
their credit cards and their you know
dual income Lifestyles uh you just had
to put your National Insurance number
anything and they sent the money in
three days no questions asked as much as
3 000 pounds
um that really shows you how different
the government views people from
different social classes you know
because if you're on that income bracket
where the government's estimating that
you're losing uh nearly four grand for
four months are not working
um and you're just getting the money no
questions asked whereas over here if
you're homeless you're fleeing domestic
violence not only are you dealing with a
department of working pensions it's
re-traumatizing you with the overbearing
surveillance the financial intimidation
the basic behavior of a domestic abuser
um but also you're getting pulled in for
random compliance meetings until to go
to the food bank because you're not
getting your money for six weeks I mean
it's actually criminal uh the level of
inequality and it's the people with the
most who make the decisions to make it
so harsh for the people with the least
and that's the thing that really well
you can see it makes me angry
I mean they're all very good points do
you think looking at this homelessness
situation is not just in Europe it's not
just the UK it's in America it just
seems to be spreading everywhere and we
don't seem to be have any any idea of
how to tackle it one of the ways of
tackle does recreate the culture where
much like ancient Greece or most people
are just looked at is absolute down and
outs that should just be driven from the
Public Public life to the margins of
society
when actually you know every every
person who is experiencing homelessness
um if you get down on a street with them
and talk to them you're going to find
trauma have as I caught some recent
tragedy
um probably addiction
and so addiction as an illness and I
know some of your viewers will just
dispute that will not go down that
cul-de-sac but I know from my own
experience as an illness
and so and until you can get the right
support for that uh you're facing the
stigma from society about the addiction
and also it's driving you to behaving
ways that really undermine your chances
of surviving and getting on and getting
the house and securing accommodation so
that's one way cultural that we do with
it we just put a mind and we come up
with a caricature or a stereotype of the
homeless addict uh because that's that
story we can live with as individuals as
we encounter these desperate people
every single day
um in terms of of how housing policy has
affected it uh we don't have enough
social housing
um and well we have our rates based
approach to housing
um and and local authorities all over
the country renege on the statutory
obligation to provide a home or a
shelter to someone who's presenting this
homeless they don't face penalties
severe enough for them to get their acts
together and to be honest their hands
have been tied since austerity
um so what you often see with
homelessness is you know it's kind of
well-meaning anti-stigma campaigns or
something it's quite hostile campaigns
which say don't give your money to
homeless people they'll only spend on
drugs I mean that was a labor Council
and Nottingham that did that one you
know and that got pulled up by
advertising standards so just shows you
the level of prejudice is widespread and
as long as that prejudice exists people
won't demand answers because what the
prejudice and the resentment at the
vulnerable creates is an out for the
political class
because as long as you
feel that it's the fault of these people
individually then you won't get in the
faces of politicians and say look we
know what you've done we're austerity we
know what you've done with housing
policy you better get this sorted
because we are fed up seeing people
begging in the street not just because
it disrupts our day and makes us feel
bad seeing it but because it's morally
reprehensible everyone should have a
right to your home give them a house
then we'll address what issues can't be
addressed by having a house seems pretty
simple well I I I the problem is and
this will feed very much into your view
of the world uh the reason we have a
housing crisis is the government cannot
afford to let housing prices stop Rising
politically because then middle class
people who own property like me I mean
in my case it's not true but most middle
class people who own property will say
well you've just made me poorer I'm
never any any government that solves the
housing problem will probably never
return into government for Generations
because the middle class people people
will absolutely hate them yeah I see
that in the book all of the policies
that you would genuinely need to
consider to make a more equal Society a
more cohesive Society a richer Society
just culturally never mind financially
it means looking at electorally
lucrative demographics out there who are
so looked after by both sides of the
political spectrum that they don't need
to get out in the streets I agree with
you man so it's it's basically your
house gains value because there are
other people who can't even get access
to house and by the way the thing is
even if you're middle class you've gotta
you've got to look out there and go well
Mike my I barely [ __ ] made it onto
the housing ladder my kids what are they
gonna do yeah um and but but you know
the corruption we've had Liam Halligan
on to talk about his book about this
like the corruption in terms of the way
housing is is run housing policies run
in this country is just uh it is deep
and and the purpose of it is
profiteering uh and politically
preserving the status quo I think the
ultimate and I wouldn't want to dwell on
this because it's been spoken about
enough but the ultimate tragic
expression of Housing and equality in
the political exclusion that's inherent
to whether you own a home or whether
you're in social housing is grenfell
fire
so there you had residents in there
who'd been campaigning for years to say
hey this place is like it's going to go
on fire one day people are gonna die
could you come and put a light in the
stairs and maybe move these bollards out
the front of the building and generally
check the electrics of the building
we've seen fires in other parts of
London this panel well not quite any of
this kind of this new front Frontage
you've put on the building we don't know
if it's safe years they campaigned about
that right yes
Place goes out in flames
it goes out in flames in 20 minutes it's
beyond the expertise of the fire service
now people talk about the safety of the
building as the approximate cause the
fire the electrics but it was the
political exclusion it was the
politicians in the council in that area
being so attuned to the interests of
property developers in the middle class
property owners in the surrounding area
that the frontage was partially designed
so that they had something a bit more
pleasant to look at from a distance
that adds value in their homes
so [ __ ] with the people who live in
there think and it's just diabolical and
it's amazing because they're still
managing a regular out of it the people
that are responsible and the
institutions are responsible for that
let's grenfell inquiring with those kind
of run to 2079. you know uh just with
all the ducking and Diving all these
people trying to get out of taking
responsibility for the manslaughter and
uh and and that in itself I think is
just that's a very tragic example of the
inequalities that stem from a basic
housing inequality does the cultural
inequalities the political inequalities
I hear everything you're saying I think
you're making some really good points
and if someone's listening to this who's
been open to your argument who maybe has
influence and power and and whatever and
we do have people like that who watch
the show or listen to the show
what are some of the like low hanging
fruit
that
we can use to make the situation more
fair and more equitable
you need to constrain The Independent
School sector in some way whether that's
revoking the charitable status or
something more radical
um you know trying to cross-pollinate
pupils from both sides of the tracks and
educational institutions so that you're
getting a fair spread of that diversity
rather than having these middle class
and working class ghettos because
there's a hell of a lot that the kids
from the welfare backgrounds could learn
from the kids in the poorer backgrounds
that let me tell you and I'm not just
talking about to study them like animals
I'm talking about all right hang on
you're really insightful oh hang on
you're really bright oh hang on you're
actually better this than me but I'm the
one that's going to get the high paying
job because I I live in that other
postcode
so there has to be some constraint
because educational inequality is where
this all starts that's where the
inequalities are cleaved and that's
where they're formalized and accelerated
um then you have to look at the labor
market right so there's lots of talk
about the kind of resurgence and Trade
union activism but we have to remember
that that Resurgence is coming from a
historic law and Trade union membership
and an absolute marginalization of the
language of equality what we have to
understand is that uh collective
bargaining workers coming together and
guaranteeing their safety their pay
their conditions this is a primary
driver of social equality this is why
you had the golden 8 golden age of
social mobility in the mid 20th century
we had record levels of inter-class
marriage you had record levels of Health
equality educational equality it
genuinely was one of the best times in
Britain's social history well the the
power of the economic power of the
government was was used to to um
was used to restrain
unfettered capitalist interests in a way
that sort of worked for both sides until
that just came along so something to do
with the labor market whether it's a
worker representation at board level
um but either way that all has to come
from the bottom the corporations can say
oh well why don't we invite you on your
your shop studs up to sit in the meeting
and we'll try and co-opt them you know
or pretend we're listening to him the
pressure's got to come from the bottom
so really that's on workers and Working
Class People and then the third thing I
think I would symbolically Britain could
break away from its relationship with
hereditary privilege by just bulldozing
the House of Lords and uh creating a
second chamber of parliament is
comprised of Ordinary People experts in
different fields politically
philosophically diverse range of people
you could do it on a rotation basis so
it could be voluntary or or it could be
called up like jury duty you get the
offer to do it and if you don't want to
do it fine
but if you had people who you know what
women who have fleeed domestic violence
or people with disabilities if they got
a chance to look at some of that welfare
reform legislation and send it back to
the house of commenting hang on I think
some of that stuff might kill people
um then that would create an opportunity
for that to be more dialogue across
these big massive chasms and so I think
taking the three of these together what
you're looking at is three different
policies that's trying to reduce that
gap between classes it's not saying Eat
the Rich Guillotines maybe Guillotine
for a couple of folks but I think it's
it's about trying to push us into
species together where we can begin to
hear each other and understand where
we're coming from and what we need
um and one of the problems we're
inequality is that it drives people
apart economically and culturally in
that discussion and dialogue becomes
really strained I'm really glad we had
you on to have this conversation because
one the more we do this the more I start
to think you know you're clearly someone
who thinks about things in a very
complex and nuanced and sophisticated
way which is why I've really enjoyed
listening to what you've had to say but
the more I do what we do
I also start to think a little bit more
like that and one of the things I
recognize is you know I still have the
question of how we pay for some of the
things that you'd like to do and I think
that's a valid question I really do but
I also think
we can't have a conversation about how
to run our society without voices like
yours being part of that conversation
doesn't mean we do everything you're
suggesting but it does mean that you
know the people who have wealth and
power and influence don't pull the
blanket all the way over to their side
yeah so I'm really glad we had this
conversation I really appreciate the way
you've talked about the stuff I really
recommend everybody get the book
um and I hope some people who are
listening take on board a lot of the
things that you've said I really do no
thanks for the opportunity I just
thought it'd be interesting to come
along cover got an account of myself
with someone on the left yeah yeah
because you know there is a caricature
out there of what the left is and
they're the only way that people on the
left can beat that caricatures
getting in a possession where they can
be held and seen and maybe coming across
a little bit more reasonable than than
some would lead you to believe
absolutely Darren we always finish our
question our question our interview with
the same question which is what's the
one thing we're not talking about that
we really should be
wow I had the whole over there have that
running in the background
um
in terms of social issues or just
whatever you want anything you want just
generally
wow man I mean I have to be honesty on
my spare time
and my spare time I love watching
computer game punditry right yeah even
computer game punditry there's no games
I like I'm watching all the punditry
Around The Last of Us remake right so
anyway I wanted to recommend to people
um which is completely tangential to
anything that we've discussed if you
haven't played it right if you have
played that then the remake's not worth
the money
but if you haven't played The Last of Us
on PlayStation
they've just made a remake of it and
it's available on the PS5 and it is a
game that will leave the kind of imprint
on you that the best albums or the best
movies or you know
admired in a beautiful sunset will leave
on you
um I mean I feel emotionally just
talking about it it's just this
beautiful Simple Story
post-apocalyptic scenario Aguero has
immunity from a virus and a pandemic
some guy she doesn't know try to take it
across the country and they form a
relationship as they go it just came to
mind there so I thought I would just
mention that rather than try to come up
with some smart ass thing no because
when I get out I hear I'm going to be
going on and read the reviews of it so I
can pick it up myself yeah it's uh I
haven't played that one but there are
some this is what people don't
understand people like to [ __ ] on
computer games some computer games are
like an interactive movie which takes
you on a beautiful Journey no that's
really as that and it has beautiful
music and the Remake is such high
fidelity compared to the original
version I mean I've just been watching
the video footage of it online and I I
think it's worth a 70 pound but I
already but spell disposable income
something may want to wait till it's
cheaper but I when I leave here and I'm
on the train now that's what I'll be
doing the whole way home so sometimes
that's an insight into people you don't
get yeah like what's our gout with
Pleasures what do they actually do when
they're not totally absorbed in there
where are the politics you know I like
watching people talk about things uh
that they're passionate about whether
it's computer games films or or stuff
like this perfect thank you so much for
coming on if people want to find you
online if they want to buy a book
where's the best place social distance
between us make sure you go and get it
I'm Matt outlooky Scottish rap on
Twitter and uh that's probably the best
place to get me and then if you can
stomach me long enough in there you'll
find out where all the other things are
perfect thank you so much for coming on
the show we really appreciate it and
thank you for watching and listening
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant interview like this one or
show and of course we will see you right
now for the bonus questions with Darren
on locals absolutely so make sure to
join locals and check those out uh but
thank you so much for watching and if
you fancy listening to this interview
and many others it's also available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
[Music]
and where are you on uh Doug drug
decriminalization
[Music]